I don't want to believe anything I want
proof and so I'm willing to say your
official narrative in the courts is
total bunk BS because you've not
explained anything properly or given us
video footage but to me if I was gonna
if I'm looking at a roulette wheel with
a bunch of different outcomes for this
story and I got to put my chips down I'm
putting it on why aren't there why isn't
there footage of it Paul turned the
cameras off because he was buying drugs
where are the security guards Paul told
them to go take a walk because his drug
dealer's showing up if I went to you and
said do you think prominent people are
doing drugs
like everyone says yes to that but
couldn't I my only problem with that
theory is couldn't a Pelosi get a posh
or drug dealer you know when I I think
of my friends in New York and La over
the years who've who have been
pharmaceutical you know they always go
to some like Rich fancy guy maybe but
think about this too the guy was a green
party leftist right yeah so if if you're
someone like Pelosi and you need
discretion you also want to make sure
you've got someone who's not going to go
it's Paul Pelosi